foreign
[Music]
I
totally understand it I understand it
but you need to control yourself
there's only one of me
happy Thursday everyone so from coast to
coast our schools our toast yes it's
time once again for
our education system sucks
it's funny because it's spelled
incorrectly
have you heard about Equitable grading I
hadn't because I'm not allowed within
100 feet of a school
they still refuse to believe I really do
drive an ice cream truck
but school districts around the country
are buying into this crap even though
many teachers aren't they think it's as
shady as a gynecologist who works out of
his garage
so what's Equitable grading really well
the grading scale begins at 50 percent
instead of zero that means if you
deserve a d that extra leg up makes it a
b or a c
picture Joy Behar
I'm sorry
but she's stepping on a scale right
where zero is actually a hundred and
fifty pounds
voila she only weighs 160 instead of
310.
Equity meanwhile homework has played
down and kids are given multiple chances
to complete the same assignments and the
same tests because if at first you don't
succeed you're probably a dumbass
grading for behavior is now banned which
includes attendance the good news in
Chicago schools you can't stab a teacher
without a permission slip
so think about what that tells a kid it
used to be half the battle showing up
but now you don't even have to do that
and when there's no deadlines for
assignments who cares if you don't do it
you create a crazy Bizarro world where
goofing Ops rewarded efforts punished
and Don lemon's still employed
hmm
good luck finding hireable people in a
few years for qualified applicants
you're going to have to look elsewhere
like death row proponents of this trash
argue that traditional grading methods
favor kids with a stable home life in
other words it's just more white
privilege but with this kind of effed up
education good luck learning anything
but at some schools that might be a good
thing a Vermont Elementary School will
no longer use the words male or female
when teaching fifth grade students sex
ed in a letter to parents officials that
Founders the memorial explained that the
changes reflect the desire to use more
gender inclusive language they will now
use person first language so boy or male
will be replaced by person who produces
sperm
and girl or female will be replaced by
person who produces eggs
which in Vermont used to be known as a
farmer
but you know why stop there huh maybe
instead of calling them School
administrators let's call them produce
of course a person who produces sperm is
male and I'd show you but this furniture
isn't Scotch guarded and a
H
I don't know what you're I don't know
what you mean and a person who produces
eggs is female that's why we use the
terms male and female you simplify
language with labels so you don't need
to include their characteristics every
time I mean imagine if you applied this
moronic logic to other words instead of
saying car you have to say large metal
object that Goes Vroom Vroom
instead of gun we say scary thing that
goes bang bang and instead of President
Biden we say old man who goes boom boom
behind a tree
everything
[Applause]
will become moronic word salad
which I guess is why Kamala supports it
I think it's very important as you have
heard from so many incredible leaders
for us at every moment in time and
certainly this one to see the moment
in time in which we exist and are
present
and to be able to contextualize it to
understand where we exist in the history
and in the moment as it relates not only
to the past but the future
you know that's some bad weed
generally when people get high they
actually have some interesting thoughts
not her
speaking of gibbering idiots in
Washington state a school district plans
to cut music classes because they feel
it promotes white supremacy culture and
significant institutional violence yeah
it's a Dave Matthews Band that's causing
all those drive-bys in Chicago
says if black kids are getting beaten
with oboes and tubas School Board member
claims kids need to miss core
instruction to attend music classes
which is just another side of inequity
dreamed up by the white man listen to
this crud
we're a school district that lives in is
surrounded by by Supremacy culture
there's nothing of
War when instrumental music that is
intrinsically white supremacist
um however the ways in which it is and
the ways in which all of our
institutions not just schools but local
government state government
our churches our neighborhoods uh
inculcate and allow white supremacy
culture to continue to be propagated and
cause significant
institutional violence are things that
we have to think about carefully as a
community
what the did you just say
seriously my God
everything everything
in colgate's White's white supremacy
talk about a wind instrument how about I
stick a flute up your ass you sick
bastard
yes
wait sorry that's institutional violence
with a wind instrument
so whenever you think education has
reached Peak absurdity something else
comes along and says hold my Eraser
that's for positive habits like working
hard or showing up and being on time
that might as well be an internship with
the Ku Klux Klan because it's just more
white privilege they'll say even though
it's truly racist to think minority kids
need those kind of excuses I feel for
parents both black and white how do you
navigate this crap but hey who needs
musical instruments when it's too much
fun watching Mom and Dad getting played
[Applause]
unlike Alec Baldwin she intentionally
shoots her targets boxes contributor
Katie bablich
he looks like your mom's old boyfriend
before he went to jail comedian Jim
Florentine
he's the stand-up whose wardrobe makes
you throw up HOSA Fox Across America or
far hey girl Jimmy Fila
and lastly she's thinner than Rudy
giuliani's comb over boxes contributor
Jimmy I believe I've heard that you do
have children or one child right one
child yes uh do you is that child in
school my son Lincoln Lincoln yes he's
14. obviously Lincoln is controversial
with the left though so now he goes by
his middle name OJ but um
hey girl hey girl good to see you yeah
this is the stupidest thing you've ever
seen as a parent because we're
prioritizing everything but what kids
need like right now one in three kids in
this country can read at a great level
right two and three can't do you
understand yes and we're focusing on all
this Anatomy stuff like we're so focused
on children's Anatomy I feel like I
bought a used laptop from Jared Fogle
you know what I mean it's disgusting but
think of it on a superficial level for a
second nobody wants to hear Motley Crue
saying smoking and the person who
produces sperm room yeah you know what
I'm saying
seriously do you want to do that you
want to go to a strip club and hear
Motley Crue saying person who produces
eggs produces eggs produces eggs which
would be girls girls that's great you
notice how me and Florentine got all the
strip club references right away hey
brother but it's dumb and anybody who
says music is a form of white supremacy
has never been on a dance floor yeah
okay
very good that's right you know
that's right
Katie it's not just that we're not just
seeing a perversion of biology we're
seeing a perversion of language that
they actually have to start taking like
like they got it backwards the word
there's a word and a definition right of
the word but now the definition is the
word right it makes no sense well I'm
just an egg basket walking around so I
don't know how you expect me to know
anything about this I like that can I
call you egg basket over here I probably
would get fired wouldn't I yeah not if I
approve it I mean that's the right thing
to do now what if I send it to you on a
text
don't do that okay all right
yeah no you're totally right like all of
our language is based on gender so male
and female our language is completely
dependent on those terms it's built
around this so when you start destroying
the language because you're just
deconstructing gender you destroy
everything and when it comes to these
schools the very people who are in the
schools that are the 77 percent of the
kids in High School can only read at a
kindergarten level they're the ones
implementing these policies because
they're lazy and bad at their jobs and
they don't want to be judged on the
future of these kids so they just say we
will give you 50 so we don't actually
have to solve the problem right and it's
really wrong because they say that
they're setting kids up for a better
future and they're really not and the
worst thing for them to do is to tell
kids that the reason why you're not
succeeding in school and the only reason
why you can read it a two-year-old level
when you are 16 years old is because of
your skin color and because white people
are keeping you down it's really wrong
to do that and it's in every facet of
society so there's no escaping from it
whereas before the message would be you
can do anything now it's you can't do
anything because of Whitey Jim you look
like the kind of parent that shows up at
school board meetings with a gun
have you been to a school board meeting
yeah I have I knew it yeah
I have and then you know the
Parent-Teacher thing and all that yeah
my kids in school and you know they say
it's an advantage if you come from
um you know parents to home parents a
nice you know yeah is it really an
advantage I mean okay so what if you
have stupid parents
but you come from a home a stable home
right like my kids got a stable home but
he's got a stupid parent yeah
so when he asked me dad can you help me
with my homework I'll go you know I'd
like to but I could barely read so
you're on your own that's true we
actually recruiting a generation that
will not be able to help their children
with their homework because they they're
not doing homework they're not doing it
or they could just do it on Google just
open up Google they're cheating anyway
so it doesn't matter yeah yeah that's
true that's true have you have you
experienced any wokism in your how old
what class is your kid in he's uh 12
he's in sixth grade sixth grade are you
experiencing any any weird stuff well
they're teaching them puberty now he's
like that he goes I got in trouble this
was just yesterday because I got in
trouble because the teacher kept saying
penis and testicles and I started
laughing I go you should yes you should
if you're not laughing at that that's
something wrong with you yeah laugh at
that every time it's said yeah yeah
they're funny words yeah they're really
funny words you know that's a case where
if they didn't want you to laugh at that
they would have chosen better words
Define and by the way he's in sixth
grade uh here's a tip from Greg two
pairs of underwear oh my God
two pairs on there forget it I mean
forget the showering thing now now he's
all I know what he's doing in there
I had to go on a payment plan my water
company now
I couldn't get him in the shower now I
can't get them out
nice
caca welcome back the number one book of
the week Amazon number three New York
Times
the most books of the week yeah can I
say this and all in all sincerity you're
welcome yeah
thanks Greg
so much I'm joking you also are you you
also taped uh Bill Maher's podcast yes I
went to LA for 20 hours to tape Club
random with Bill Maher comes out on
Sunday yeah it's gonna be something else
you did on you it's going to be
something else how many times did he hit
on you stop it
um that means a lot I had a great time
it's a great conversation do not watch
it if you're easily offended um
speaking of all this stuff yes I might I
don't think I'm like super right wing
but I guess maybe I am because I think
it's a little weird to be talking to
kids about their sperm yeah yeah exactly
like I I mean they didn't it there's I
think they forgot what they were talking
about or what because this whole idea
was they're sex and then your gender
identity is whatever you you choose that
it is so okay I was born a man but I
identify as a woman so that's what male
and female meant even according to them
this you still need something to
describe what chromosomes you have right
and I think male and female are just
shorter than walking and like telling
kids you person who produces sperm yeah
it just sounds gross it sounds like
there's not a word for it yeah it's like
it's weird it's gross pedophile I didn't
know what was this Farm producer I
didn't it's good to know yeah yes no so
now if I'm too tired to have sex with my
girlfriend I go look it's a supply chain
issue mayor Pete
thank you
oh my God that's funny I think I need to
take a shower now yes I feel a little
dirty inside I definitely do I just got
off the plane yeah I could smell you
from here that's not true uh the
audience is turning on me
don't worry I'm used to it all right hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else